Elon Musk came out he himself having
been defamed by the ADL and said to
clear our platform's name on the matter
of anti-Semitism it looks like we have
no choice but to file a defamation
lawsuit against the Anti-Defamation
League oh the irony
love it so absolutely go after the ADL
you should go after some of the other
groups too though it's not just the ADL
it's groups like right wing watch which
is a project of people for the American
way which is a one of the most
ironically named groups in America
because it is a handful of Elites for a
very Un-American way there are several
others out there where these groups
exist they're watching the show right
now and they try to clip out little
pieces of the show and get us all fired
and they try to censor people on on
social media my one request to Elon
though is as we take them all down
please don't take down my publicists at
Media Matters take down the ADL take
down right wing watch do whatever you
want but please I have no interest in
finding a new set of publicists